lienz handy ihr wart ihr beide mit boris
becker zusammen und das unmittelbar
hintereinander
wie schafft man es dass so guter freund
zu sein wir wollen wir haben
das wollte er den guten geschmack
aber wie kam das ihr konntet euch ja
glaub ich schon vorher können das
wirklich frauen auch so ein bisschen
ausblenden dass deine freundschaft
stärker ist ja ich glaube wenn ich ein
bisschen erziehen will ist am anfang
noch am anfang wenn die schmerzen erst
mit zusammen war und überhaupt keine
freundin habe danach haben wir uns
teilweise sogar pre krieg ja ich denke
man hat es gehört schon eine gewisse
reife dazu ich glaube es hat uns auch
sehr geholfen dass wir das wir mütter
geworden sind dass das hat man natürlich
auch noch mal eine extreme verantwortung
gegeben und reiße und und es ist einfach
so dass seit dieser gewisse her mir und
lily kennt die geschichte schon vor ganz
langer zeit gesagt hat dass wenn die
umstände an dass lehrende reli und ich
beste freundinnen sein würden und es ist
so dass die umstände jetzt anders sind
und geht tatsächlich beste freundinnen
geworden sind und von daher hatte er
damals recht behalten
[Musik]